cost me a billion dollars a year to not  know what to do to make a billion  dollars or I do know how to make a  billion dollars and I just have to wait  and pay down my time debt which is what  I feel like I'm doing right now I'm just  paying down time understanding whether  it's a lack of knowledge or it's just a  timeline thing like those are big  differences you could be doing the right  thing but just be 10 years behind when  it's going to come to fruition you will  get outsized Returns on the knowledge  and the lessons that you will learn you  want to pay that ignorance down as fast  as you can because as soon as you have  that knowledge you'll be able to  Skyrocket straight to 20 50 100 500 000  a month very quickly because you know  how to do it